so the family had a motto when your wife
was sick
what was that motto she was going in for
a 13-hour surgery the last thing I did
was blow her a kiss and say just keep
swimming Jennifer Aniston joining Ellen
DeGeneres's Christmas giveaway special
and on Tuesday's episode she's moved to
tears as they surprised the Kimball
family with a Christmas they won't
forget after daughter Elise reveals
their mom died from cancer when she was
three and the dad Jeff recently lost his
job oh my god
I mean what would your mom say right now
if she were here she would just be so
happy she she would be Alan she was your
biggest fan so she would be like move
over cousin closer that's so sweet and I
know this time of year is important to
you because she really loved Christmas
that's when Jen and Ellen reveal what
exactly they did to make their holiday a
little bit brighter while you've been
here we've been at your house so this is
what your house looked like before and
now this is what it looks like
Jan and Ellen also played a little game
of telephone with a Kimball family your
family have a beautiful home where you
get to spend the holidays together to go
to the mall let's go to the mall get
specs and even though they botched the
message Ellen gifted them a hundred and
fifty thousand dollars the antics didn't
stop there though Ellen's audience also
got a few gifts you're getting a $500
Visa gift think we should send them
someplace exotic
[Applause]
you're getting Park tickets airfare and
a six-day trip to Abu Dhabi Ellen's
greatest night of Giveaways premieres
Tuesday December 10th and it's been a
big week for Jen who has earned both a
Golden Globe and SAG Award nomination
for her work on the morning show the
show itself the world behind the scenes
it was just sort of and the timing it
was ripe and it was ready and then as we
as you know you know me too happened and
then the whole world turned upside down
so we kind of - you know wonderfully and
willingly incorporate that issue into
into the show
[Music]